yeah i love this the name's agatha hart
we knew it we already knew baby
lovely to finally meet you dear
wow they made us look like a fool
welcome back to new rock stars one
division
just revealed it was agatha all along
agnes is confirmed to be the witch
agatha harkness
she's got the boys she's got wanda she's
got our
hearts but now that monica rambo has
re-entered the game
as a super-powered individual maybe
photon
can she save everyone what
does the
oh right before i sneeze oh i'm so sorry
bless you
you gotta be careful because you don't
want your soul to escape your body there
are witches
abound ready to snatch it up and gobble
it up
well jessica welcome this is inside
marvel
this is our one division after show i'm
eric voss here with jessica clements how
are you what did you think of that it
was
wild and it was so funny because i was
like really calm for the entire episode
and then when that song started playing
i was like
chef kiss they gave i love it was so
good it was so good and i couldn't tell
is it the are we doing the adams family
or was it the monsters
to me it felt more monstersy has more of
the slower
yeah double snap online people like with
a nice adams family and i was like i
think it's because you guys don't know
the monsters and you only know the adams
family
yeah monsters have had a beat to it
oh i loved it i'm so in love with it and
i can't wait to see her outfit
i can't wait to see her outfit just a
taste just a taste so far
but i want to see that full thing i'm so
excited well in this episode jessica and
i are going to explain
agatha right not agnes anymore she is
agatha
what her plan is what that book was uh
what pietro's appearance and the
post-credits scene means yeah
if you haven't watched it yet there is a
post-credits scene in the middle of the
credits go watch it
uh we're gonna talk about monica's
powers and we're gonna talk about the
meaning of that next
antidepressant commercial that i was
able to shockingly predict accurately
in a video earlier this week oh good job
it was everyone on my twitter was like
voss is always right and i'm not always
in here
oh okay i feel like your records are
always like so many rights
more rights than i would expect um
you're right you were right
i was so mad about the sparky thing
because i was like oh my god i
freaking said it i was like well i don't
i don't want it to be right i
you know if a dog is gonna die on screen
you'd want it to be natural causes
unfortunately
she did murder it we're gonna talk about
why she murdered him though
yeah let's talk about it um now tomorrow
will be my in-depth shot by shot
breakdown of all the easter eggs you
missed in the episode now if you happen
to be in the comments of this video and
you see someone says
eric miss this new deal jessica forgot
to say this
if you see that you have my permission
to yell at that person because this
isn't the damn
breakdown that is tomorrow yeah people
don't get it
they'll still do it people don't get
stuff it's fine it's tough but you can
yell
i am wearing our new latest obsession
shirt it's an unusual couple it's got
secret augmented reality easter eggs
it's amazing we still have some but
uh supplies are running out you can
still get one at newrockstarsmerch.com
but the real cool thing is if you get
the shirt you get the opportunity to
write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of these inside
marvel episodes
let's see who do we have down there
vaughn crest asks what are the
possibilities that the cameo is baron
mordo
the show is going to lead up to doctor
strange good point good point we have
some thoughts on the cameo this episode
michael lombardo asks uh or says love
you guys thanks mike uh
do you think evan peters is sticking
around for phase four
we need a speedster wanda the
i don't know i don't know um we'll talk
more about pietro as well and then tom
hopkins says
c and br are the new cosmic rays hello
fantastic four
i mean one would think by uh monica tom
hobbit hop it i almost said tom hopkins
tom hopkins hopping all over it senor
scratchy over there tom hopp
uh now we are simulcasting this live
on stereo you can get this app for free
and follow us at stereo.com
new rockstars if you're listening to us
on stereo now stick around for a bonus
segment at the end of the show in which
we're going to react to your voicemails
in real time if you missed this live
broadcast you can catch us next week at
8 am pacific
stereo.com new rockstars
so uh let's actually take a question
right now from
our stereo listeners we have one queued
up right now here we go
what in the world else do you think this
woman
agatha could be controlling now ah
very good question set to the avengers
theme back there
um so yeah jessica our first wtf
wanda the has agnes
aka ag the harkness been doing all along
jessica and i are going to talk about
this together so jessica
first off i think let's catch everyone
up when wanda goes down to
agnes's creepy basement agnes steps out
and reveals her true identity as
agatha harkness that was probably real
in the
coolest reveal in the world uh catherine
hahn has been crushing it we knew
something was suspicious about her we
knew from the moment she was announced
as a nosy neighbor that she might
actually be agatha harkness uh her name
seems like an amalgamation of those two
first and last name right um in the
comics
agatha harkness is the witch who often
accompanies wanda she was there in the
west coast avengers storyline that we
keep referencing and
uh after she gets the warded she keeps
showing back up again and again and
again
uh most of the time it's in a role of uh
some kind of
nefarious entity that's manipulating
wanda uh but sometimes uh
a neutral uh chaotic figure who doesn't
might kind of be on wanda's side and
some stuff but either way she is a witch
she often is putting her in spells
wiping her memory and that kind of thing
you know doing which things wiping her
doing you know you know witches which
which is gonna witch this episode has as
we're talking about that monster style
credit sequence and it reframes all this
as agatha show actually
agatha all along and jessica did you
hear this i think that was kathryn hahn
singing the female part of that
that's what i thought yeah i haven't
been able to like confirm that online
though but i did think about that
because
uh agatha catherine han does have a
background in music so
yeah she's a great singer uh she's not a
great singer at step brothers
unfortunately it's so funny to see her
pretend not to be able to sing because
she's got pipes
she can actually sing and then she's in
um central park on apple tv if you guys
haven't seen it because it's really good
and she's a great singer in that
but yes keep going um so yeah we see her
hover down
in this black witch dress black boots
and then she warps reality before we see
the full costume but that costume is
gonna be sick
when we see it next episode or the one
after
and then we see her warping reality she
is warping the reality using her
violet magic uh into this 50s reality
moments before she knocked on wanda's
door
uh and then we see all these moments
throughout the series that agnes has
been a bit suspicious like we see
her unleashing senor scratchy during the
magic show in episode two
we see her kind of like triggering herb
to malfunction
interestingly we see her picnicking on
their lawn when pietro knocks on
the door with magic kind of pushing him
in there suggesting that
at least the two of them are in cahoots
or that
they are working together in some way
but it looks like she was kind of
compelling him
to that front door um then we see
her in the car when she's talking with
vision last episode clearly faking it
like i'm ready for my close-up
and then she says she killed sparky the
dog
come on it hurt but it was also
so good it was satisfying to get some
closure there so
and then she straight up just turned and
said and i killed sparky too i said okay
give her the academy award yeah give her
the oscar i love i'm tired of that she
needs a awards yeah
she's an emmy sitting behind the camera
during the interview segment from this
episode
which we had heard the voice of the
director uh and it sounded like it was a
male voice
but it might have been her doing like
she was doing it like an octave low i
read when i rewatched it i was like this
is definitely catherine han just doing a
lower isn't that awesome i love that
this episode is so
it's people are like it's a filler
episode but i'm like i don't care if it
was a filler up so catherine han just
straight up ruined the game with this
like she filler the way cream is filler
in an oreo
yeah so we need it we need it that's all
we want now the implication jessica
is that everything bad in west view
maybe even the hex itself was actually
agatha's creation
now wanda must have some control because
it seemed like it was her decision to
expand the hex freeze everything last
episode
but for reasons we'll talk about i think
that
decision could have been one that was in
a way an extension of what
agatha wanted um now agatha apparently
lied about being a victim to vision in
order to get him to try to leave
right which would lead to wanda
expanding the hex
did agatha want to be expanded or did
agatha just want vision to get the
f out of there what do you think why do
you think she lied division last episode
jessica oh my god well now that you said
that now i see that happening but that
seems too intricate for her to know that
that was gonna happen that she would
expand the bubble
okay maybe she thought that she could
also be like um because i wouldn't have
been like
i'm gonna lead him out there so she
makes it bigger i would be like i'm
gonna lead her out there so he she goes
out there and destroys the world outside
what if agatha is stuck in the bubble
too and she's trying to get out the
bubble so she needs
uh she needs my oh my god i keep doing
this she needs wanda to do something
just drastic so she can get out yeah um
because there has to be some sort of
hold that's connected like that
because it it's too messy to be like oh
hopefully he'll fall on the ground and
then she'll expand this world
yeah you're right that probably is one
too many steps to plan but
but i get but i get it i get it though
what if like uh
she just wanted vision to leave like now
that the kids are born now the kids are
their powers are manifesting she doesn't
need vision
in him questioning everything and him
confusing uh wanda like that
is why she brought in pietro to try to
control wanda a bit better to keep her
there while she can try to get these
kids from her
because clearly pietro wanted the kids
too he was trying to get in there and
wedge between the relationship in that
case i feel like she's just like now
breathing underwater um agnes because
she's just like
now she's like okay this machine is here
i was expecting just like
because now we have like two villains we
have hayward and now we have agnes for
sure
so it's like i feel like there's so many
hands now that they're just like
if she's trying to get them out she's
doing a horrible job at doing so yeah
i don't know i i don't know what her
connection to vision would be
because she's just like every time she
talks to him as a mess
but there is something she's like
leeching on to wanda to get in
or get out of something i think and i
also think it's just agnes now i do not
think there's another person okay
yeah yeah we'll get into that um now i
think you bring up a good point with
hayward jessica because
uh i don't i'm i'm kind of wondering if
agnes
slash agatha and hayward i kind of feel
like they are not on the same page that
they're they're
not trying to exploit wanda in slash
vision for different reasons i think
hayward was trying to exploit vision
wanda interfered with that and that uh
agatha
used wanda's rage over hey we're doing
that
to try to exploit her further now with
this hex i don't think
uh agnes and hayward are working
together i might be wrong not at all
i mean it could be helping or it could
be helping
um agatha in whatever she's trying to do
ultimately she's probably like oh
they're really messing with her like i'm
messing with her but they are like
really messing with her
so she could be just like feeding off
that and luring her out there but then
like
she turned away monica right she
literally turned away monica and said
well i guess monica was going to tell
her the truth
and make the world crumble so she was
like nah that's not going to happen not
my
not my hex well it's interesting because
agatha does kind of reveal herself now
she shows her cards
i was wondering why now i'm thinking
jessica maybe it's because she now has a
kid she's late
she has what she wants it's too late for
wanted to do anything about it
and it's interesting there's that little
moment where she tells the camera i did
bite a kid once
uh so does that mean that she's trying
to
consume these kids like a classical
witch hansel and gretel she's trying to
eat them
or uh could it be like just a sign of
her being
hostile to the kids and that this could
be connected to something else the the
whole
truly unleash hell demon spawn and that
we're seeing an adaptation of the
these kids are part of mephisto's soul
and agatha's part
yeah we're getting the world now of like
um
agatha is the villain i didn't really
necessarily think agatha was the villain
in the comics i was more so just like oh
she's helping her she's kind of helping
her yeah she's kind of a conduit
uh in the comments so i was like i
when we knew that she was gonna be in
there i was like oh she's probably
helping wanda like i kept being like
maybe it's this maybe she is bad but
maybe she's ultimately working for
someone else so she's not the villain
and now that she clearly it's like it's
her all along and she is the villain
i was like yeah i was like oh okay so
she is bad so they could be piecing
together because this isn't going to be
exactly like the comic books
so they could be using some of the like
because when we saw the insects i was
like oh it could be nightmare or
mephisto but then i was also like it's
also just like a witch and devil
trait of having like cicadas and a
rabbit so i was like what if this is
just
agnes and we're taking things that kind
of lean mephisto kinda lean nightmare
but it's just agnes see i read that that
uh cicada as like silence of the lambs
like chloe starling in um in the house
seeing them off and be like that's the
this is the guy in that moment of like i
need to go check down
stairs and see what's going on in the
basement oh that's nice i truly was like
oh she changed these
kids into an insect and a rabbit you
know one of them already wants a rabbit
i was like i was also like i was when i
rewound it and looked at that rabbit
because i was like
okay that rabbit is one of the children
what is it doing that's weird it was
just like nibbling on the grass
okay i don't know if it's a child well i
have a theory about that
um but we got to talk about this book
jessica um
in my eyes the dark hole this has got to
be the dark hole yeah
so it has to be yeah uh for anyone
wondering the dark hold is the marvel
book of the dead
uh it's kind of like the ancient spell
book that is tied with all the
supernatural stuff
in the marvel universe it's appeared in
agents of shield
uh i think it was in the runaways too
but uh
this has a different cover a different
design with like interesting
symbols on it um now here's my thinking
jessica
when we saw doctor strange a couple
years ago some people believe
that one of the books in the camaratage
library could be the darkhold
it would make sense that's kind of the
library that contains all the spell
books
um and if that is the case if this is
connected to the sorcerer's
side of uh of the mcu it might be based
in
eldritch magic we just did a big
question episode a couple weeks ago
about the different kinds of magic in
the mcu
and that might explain the hexagon
because eldritch magic
is all based on geometric shapes and
just interesting geometric shapes
and then in this case the hexagon could
represent dark magic
connected to the the eldritch
way of looking at things um do you think
that's it or are they saying this is
gonna be a whole new different kind of
magic in the mcu
well when you say like that's the thing
when you say like that i believe you
when you say hey when you say anything i
believe you should be a lawyer
um i believe i tried to i gave up go to
law school
oh god boss never give up oh but if i
didn't give up i wouldn't be here with
you talking about one yes you could
yes you could there's always time to go
back for disney yeah
yeah so i no i believe that that's a
good theory
i was more so i didn't even think about
what i was thinking about when i saw
that book immediately i was like okay
now they have their ties to doctor
strange
also are we sure that he has the book i
know in the comics he has the book but
like in the mcu
he might not have the book and that's
why like agatha has it yeah the dark
hold hasn't been established in the mcu
prime as of until yet unless you
consider agents of shield part of the
mcu there's
yes we made there but in the main mcu
that kevin feig this is the first time
that kevin feige produced property has
had the dark hold in it
so that's uh they can kind of do
whatever they want with it now i think
i understand thinking that he i don't
know maybe he
lost it yeah i mean that's the most
important book in history
well i think the idea is that like you
know if if kaiselius's gang could break
into that library and steal the book of
caglio
and tear out a page about dealing with
like dark dimension spells
like their security there kind of sucks
yeah if yeah i'm sure agatha could break
in and take that i mean wong's just
sitting there listening to beyonce on an
ipod
stream oh yeah flipping around making
stuff so i feel like anybody oh yeah
oh my god they definitely could have
taken the book but yeah that makes sense
but also i feel like um with the
hex magic the dark magic
i think this book has a lot to do with
the whole nexus commercial
yeah um and so i will probably get into
that more
but i was mainly just like watching it
and i was like after seeing the nexus
commercial i was like oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah every kind of like
really powerful being can go there got
it got it got it and then we got the
darkhold book and i was like okay so are
we connecting this to doctor strange
blade i hope so like everything now
hopefully it gets brought into this dark
blade has to get that book yeah look
blade's gonna get that book and he's
gonna do it
and my husband's gonna do his spells
blade is my husband i said it now
and i want that to be known through oh
my god if ralph it's just mahershala ali
is blade it would make no sense
but i would lose my damn mind oh i'm
going to flip my
the people on stereo can't see how much
i'm reacting to this right now but
wow what what i would i don't know how i
would read oh i don't know how
like okay i don't know how to explain
this but when like agatha came
out when agatha came out and was just
like
oh honey you thought you're the only
magical person here
i retr i like i resurrected it was like
seeing wicked live when they did like
defying gravity
it was like rupaul's drag race when
sasha velour
ripped off her wig and the roses fell i
truly was so
shook i uh yeah kelly and i just watched
wizard of oz this week uh re-watched it
uh just because we hadn't seen it
forever it's so great it's such a
classic
margaret hamilton is amazing
in that movie and it's like now watching
you can definitely see
some uh notes of that in catherine
hahn's performance of just like
i don't give a [ __ ] you know it's so
great
and she kills a dog unhinge my jaw
and like scream like a snake i don't
know why that would be the case
i would to this because it was amazing
someone on twitter said
um the witches of west view and it like
hurt me and now it's stuck to me and i
was like this is a good
it's pretty much make it into a spin-off
of disney oh yeah all right jessica
let's talk about wanda and pietro
because
pietro has been kind of dominating the
conversation in recent weeks he does pop
up in this post-credits scene i hope you
guys all saw it
it's it's monica's snooping down into
agusta's basement
she opens the shutter doors and then he
goes snoopers gonna snoop
i love it and then we cut to black um
and we also saw during that munster's
credit sequence that it was agatha who
brought pietro to wanda's door
so it would suggest that at the very
least agatha and pietro are working
together
doesn't necessarily mean that pietro
himself is like nightmare or mephisto he
could just be a kind of puppet
upon a tool used by agatha but
for now at least it seems that evan
peters is not
quicksilver from the x-men franchise
that marvel's not jumping to that yet
and this is just kind of
agatha's stunt casting trick um how do
you feel about that jessica do you think
fans are gonna accept that it sucks i
will say that as a fan
i was truly like oh this is gonna be fun
can't wait to see where he goes
but after seeing him appear he she
obviously like crea and also that
episode where he showed up and knocked
on the door
wanda was like very sympathetic and was
like i didn't make this happen
during the fight she was like i don't
know who's at the door so it was clearly
agatha
created this bean based off of her
brother
put him in there and was just like boop
here you go
and so that's why i think she's just a
min it's like a minion created by agatha
to like torment but also to work for
agatha it's just
a whatever she could have done it
episodes ago
but like she needed it in that moment
so i think i think the fun part is like
why did she choose the quicksilver from
like the sony versus or from the phone
quicksilver from
yeah from the fox yeah from the fox
versus like the mcu's quicksilver and
it's
i was like maybe she didn't know what
piatro actually looked like
so she yeah it created this i think it's
a not too like agnes being a witch
agatha harkness being a witch
you can kind of transcend reality they
mention nexus we'll talk about what that
means but i think
there still might be a multiversal
connection here i'm not saying that
they're going to bring in the fox x-men
so soon but i think it's implied that
she can kind of see us that she can talk
to us
and she's winking directly at us and
that's what evan peters is all about
if he shows up more i'm very here for it
but realistically i was like
he's gonna die with the hex yeah like as
soon as the hex goes he goes
we're never gonna see him again and then
we might see aaron taylor johnson and
like later that'd be cool because i mean
yeah i think kevin finds
out the universe and i went to this in a
video earlier this week i just don't
think he's gonna own up to every weird
movie and plot point that happened in
the fox sex
franchise he has his own mutant plan
that's going to be great and i think at
the end of the day it's going to be
better than what we saw
there's some great movies i'm very just
going to talk about this in big question
this week some great movies of
x-men first class the very first x-men
definitely worth watching
but it's of a different era and feige's
looking forward he's not looking
backward i don't think
absolutely i can't wait till we get our
hands on it it's gonna be so
much like it's gonna be great um all
right let's talk about the rabbits in
your scratchy and how he connects with
it so the rabbit comes back
greater importance uh you know when he
came up in episode two we were talking
about how he could be referenced to old
scratch which is a nickname for the
devil but
agatha's son is nicholas scratch so it
could just as easily be
that um do we think that uh
this what do you think this rabbit's
gonna end up being jessica i'm such an
idiot
i know so much about nicolas scratch
because he's just like he becomes
basically a bad guy
uh essentially the comic books but like
depending on who you think is bad i
think he's a bad guy
because he kind of throws his mom under
the bus but um
i'm so stupid because it wasn't until
someone on twitter was like yeah
nicholas scratch
senior scratchy and i was like oh my god
i didn't even put those two
together i i feel like it's just a nod
to a son because what would what would
the perks be of bringing him
into the universe i mean yeah i think
it's either a knight
or like it could be both like it could
be uh i'm not
off the mephisto train yet yeah i think
it's more the devil than it is herself
i think it's more a spiritual thing than
it is her child now
and here's why i think this jessica the
basement this basement was covered with
all these vines
and they seemed to be stemming from
these purple flowers that were all over
her yard
she was wearing purple this episode that
is the color of agatha
um and i'm thinking these plants could
be the wundigor
everbloom this is agatha's plant that
grows in her yard
and in the tom king vision comics that's
the plant that sparky the dog
eats or has eaten by the time virginia
has killed the dog and then she finds
this plant and his remains in his
stomach
and then she eats this plant and it
allows you to see
visions of the future see projections of
what life could be as you feel pain as
you cry
and i wonder if that could tie into what
the spell is what this hex is on wanda
is like this plant because think about
it uh
the first time she walks up to their
house she brings a house plant to them
and it has a purple ribbon around it
uh and throughout this plant stays in
their house it warps with the house
uh and then uh when billy is feeding the
rabbit he's feeding it like
leaves of a plant uh right next to the
dark hold
there was a more leafy plant right there
uh and i'm thinking maybe sparky was
digging around in the yard and started
to eat those and that's why agatha
killed him oh
yeah oh why would you grow that outside
then
you're just asking for a dog to come eat
your yours well
maybe you could assume that your
neighbors should keep their dogs on
you a leash of north hollywood leash
your dogs
leash your dog's no hope
this is so funny this is when they start
putting up the signs that are like
beware of dog or like
get your dog
i'm a cat person yeah that dog
definitely was eating those drug plants
and she was like
and then zipped them to death no no no
no no zipped up
um yeah i could completely that's like
such a huge nod of you digging so deep
that i'm sure that people are probably
missing they're probably like oh yeah
it's just like
its own dungeon hell of course this is
the witch's life just the top layer of
this seven layer bean dip of how far
i'm gonna dig babies uh tomorrow's video
i got so many clues that i'm finding in
here i'm gonna
you definitely dig and yeah i hate all
the way to hell you're a mole
it's a groundhog day was like two weeks
ago now let's continue to talk about the
production design of this basement so
there were
hexagons containing these weird odd
symbols
um and there were bones everywhere
animal remains
and there were statue faces on the walls
and
jessica there was an animal skull that
looked like at first i thought it was a
goat i think it's a ram
not scratchy oh what'd you say
or a scratch i was like it's not i was
like it's not the dough it's not the dog
but it looks like a ram at first i'm
like is this baphomet
is this like a demonic kind of like
thing when you see a curved horned
animal
skull on a wall your first thought is
satanic ritual
yeah she's a witch she's a witch and i
think the question we have to talk about
jessica is
she is the villain here it was agatha
all along but
is she working alone because paul
bettany's interview came out this week
from esquire suggesting that
some unknown actor still has not been
revealed someone he's going to have
fireworks with
and in this episode it looks less likely
that one division is going to explore
x-men
and more likely that it's going to
explore dark magic and
i know there are some rumors out there
that this villain is going to be
nightmare i think that's possible i just
say based on this episode and last
episode
wanda says she's not asleep and i think
the idea of sleep versus
awake is very big deal to nightmare uh
wand is awake right now she's just under
a trance and i
think as we're getting more and more
into witchcraft in the satanic imagery
in the dark hold
this is the realm of mephisto
and it doesn't mean he's the one behind
it all i think agatha is behind it all
right um but i just think this could be
something she did
to please her partner i think she is
linked with someone else we have not
seen
i feel like she has a partner but i
don't know how big they are they have to
do with this
but they might appear like i don't know
especially when they
i'm not saying that they don't do this
but to put the song
it was agatha all along and then be like
also her
no i agree like wait a minute you just
said that totally agreed
and i prefer catherine han being the big
bad of this series because she's so
great
yeah yeah i i wouldn't want to undercut
her
you know insidiousness i'm just saying
like she could have
she must have some kind of silent
partner yeah behind the scenes and that
doesn't mean that silent partner has to
be important to
what happens in the plot of the story
going forward it could just be like
a voice on the other side of the shadow
that she is communing with
as she's reading this darkhold book but
i think they're the evidence is still
there if
all you uh mephisto mephisto heads i'm
one of you i think
we still have two big episodes
oh that's funny i think what i will
predict is that
she will get out of the hex she will um
not prevail so to speak but she won't
die within the hex
and then we'll get like a little like
after credit scene of her going back to
her hovel
wherever she is um in the mountains and
maybe we see either the demon that like
helped create wanda or we see mephisto
or we see that
and that's like that nod that's like oh
this is gonna be coming into the mcu
eventually i don't think i don't know i
think this is going to be like this is
all agatha
let's she's the queen and then
maybe we'll see like oh here's a little
bit i i don't think they're going to
like
how you said i don't think they're going
to undercut her being the star right now
right
it's and we also only have two episodes
you can't add too much you can't add too
much yeah and it's the same thing of
like when you're watching any kind of
fiction or reading any kind of story
um there's like you know any kind of
epic myth
there are the earthbound heroes and
villains that are
fighting each other but there are the
gods up in the heavens
and the demons down below who are using
them as champions
the ones we relate to are the earthbound
heroes but it doesn't deny the existence
of these divine forces that are
trying to at least observe and pick a
winner and bet on a winner
so i mean uh yeah i don't want
uh anyone else to be the villain other
than agatha right now because she's so
great
yeah um in terms of like the story
mechanics but she could have a silent
partner that she's either trying to
please or overthrow
or whatever it is and if she does have a
silent partner
i i kind of feel like the evidence is
there for it to be mephisto again
you can't throw that crap in here for me
at least i'll be pissed if it's
nightmare because you
you just gave us the dark hole right you
literally just gave us
the most demonic thing in the universe
and how are you gonna be like
psych it's nightmare i'm gonna be like
get out of here
get out of here the truth is jessica and
i'm not i'm not encouraging anyone to do
this i have been told that there are
some leaks that are out there
and these leaks are not leaks they're
most of the time they're just like
people who go on 4chan and say stuff and
claim to be an inside source and then
they're taken as real and then like
people believe them
even when they're wrong it's like it's
like q and on [ __ ] sometimes they make
some general statements that are
easily proven right and i think
nightmare was tied into one of those and
that's why people were saying oh it's
nightmare but i don't know it's also fun
to just
ignore those please do ignore those
because i i literally
ignore it i'm like nah i'm gonna watch
this and be stunned on my own
um all right we uh are gonna continue
with uh
the nexus with what happened to monica
because a lot of other stuff happened
this episode first we want to thank some
friends who helped us make it
our friends at expressvpn thank you for
sponsoring this episode so netflix hides
thousands of shows from you based on
your location right and then
they have the nerve to increase their
prices on you starting at the end of
this month what
they're gonna raise their prices again
instead of canceling your subscription
protest
here's what i recommend you do get your
full money's worth by using expressvpn
like i do
so what's on netflix in your country is
completely different from what someone
in the uk or japan has on theirs
and when you use expressvpn you can
control which country you want netflix
to think you're in
expressvpn has over 90 countries to
choose from the newest season of rick
and morty isn't on the us netflix but
with just one tap of a button
xor soupy and let's let me change my
location to the uk so that i can watch
it
usex for sap to unlock shows on other
streaming services too like
bbc iplayer which is free and only
available in the uk
uh expressvpn is also super fast and
works on your iphone your tablet
your laptop even smart tvs so that you
can watch your shows on the big screen
with zero buffering
so be smart stop paying full price for
streaming services and only getting
shows to a fraction of their content get
your money's worth at expressvpn.com
one division don't forget to use our
link so that you can get those three
extra months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
one division expressvpn.com one division
to learn more
uh we also wanna thank our friends at
bombas for sponsoring this episode
so bombas makes the most comfortable
socks in the history of feet
they have literally rethought every
little detail in the socks that we wear
to make them
way more comfortable i just got a few
pairs of bamba socks and i love them
they're comfortable for walking around
the house and just socks
or when i strap on some shoes and
actually attempt to move about the world
to walk darla
uh but these socks do more than just
keep my feet cozy they help give back
to the most vulnerable members of our
community because every pair of socks
that you purchase from bombas bombas
donates a pair to someone in need the
generosity of bomba's customers has
allowed them
to donate over 40 million pairs of socks
through their nationwide effort of 3 000
giving partners
and the impact is more powerful than
ever to those experiencing homelessness
these socks represent the dignity of
putting on clean clothes
a small comfort that's actually very
especially important right now
so give a pair when you buy a pair and
get 20 off your first purchase at
bombas.com
marvel that's b o m b a s
dot com slash marvel for 20 off your
first purchase bombas.com
marvel and lastly we want to thank our
friends at stereo for sponsoring us
we know you have a ton of questions and
a whole bunch of theories about this
episode and we're gonna
address a lot of them in our bonus q a
segment that will only be
on stereo jessica and i are live on
stereo as we record this
stereo is this fun audio app with live
social conversations that we've been
having a blast with lately new rockstars
has three
weekly shows on the app including this
live inside marvel taping every friday
and after we're wrapped on the youtube
show jessica and i are gonna answer
all of our stereo listeners questions
that we can get to uh
join us every monday wednesday and
friday over on the stereo app for new
rockstars 3 news shows
so we got this one and then new
rockstars news with me and phillip on
wednesdays and then our editors show on
mondays
download the stereo app and follow us at
stereo dot com new rockstars or click
that link in the description
again that's stereo stereo.com new
rockstars we're having a great time
on stereo follow new rockstars and get
notified every time we go live
all right we're going to go back to this
episode here jessica we have another
wanda the [ __ ] that we're going to take
from stereo let's see what they said
you were right about the commercial what
do you think
it means what is nexus so weirdly
yeah i uh you know i made this
prediction in a video earlier this week
uh to anyone asking i don't work for
marvel marvel doesn't give me anything
they don't tell me anything yes he does
he's being
nice being courteous but he gets this if
i did i
don't look at the wrong but he's the
leaking he's the leak
in the fight
oh my god he's the gossip girl
yeah yeah i mean really this is a
prediction i just made based off of the
themes on the show
and like i don't know i studied a lot of
journalism and advertising in college
and
you kind of know based off of what the
history of advertising is in this
country
how they target ads that women and the
one ad missing from that trend was
a pharmaceutical antidepressant ad
that's been dominating advertising for
the past 15 years
and knowing that the show's all about
juana's mental health it's like how are
they
not going to include an ad like that
it's like snl all their
ad uh parodies are based off of these
antidepressants so or
shingles so nexus let's talk about nexus
jessica
because nexus uh is you know a reference
to
the fact that wanda maximoff is a nexus
being
she is not tied down to any one reality
she can connect to all kind of realities
that's how house of m works is that she
is kind of the fulcrum on which all
these at all these realities get flipped
and she stays the constant but does she
know that i don't think she knows it at
this point
someone's gonna have to explain so how
do you think that's gonna get revealed
to her jessica
i have no idea i have no idea
let's show them about answers
and i just said i don't know at least i
have the courage
and bravery to say that i i'm i don't
know
i okay so there's a couple ways this
could go but i think um
a main one is maybe later down the line
when we start talking more about doctor
strange
because doctor strange definitely knows
he is and he knows about the
nexus realities like he's aware of it
probably in the math of like
i have to be here you have to be here
two can live in this part at this time
like
i'm sure he's aware so maybe he's the
one that explains that to wanda
i feel like one is gonna learn about it
eventually but we're i don't know she's
gonna learn about it
in one division there's not enough time
now for her to get like a run down
maybe i mean unless unless agatha tells
her unless agatha attacks i think that'd
be a pretty
um revealing thing to tell uh wanda that
she has that level of power
um because i think at this point she's
like you're in my clutches there's
nothing you can do i will tell you my
evil plan
and that information will be used to
blow up in my face oh
why did i put an off switch here why did
i tell you you were a nexus being damn
it i'm a jack-in-the-box now that's
truly that
she'll probably do that honestly but
then i feel like wanda won't be
surprised she'll be like
yeah i know i created an entire world
like
yeah i mean this uh the fact that it
shows up in a commercial is interesting
right because it means that
wanda so it seems like all these
commercials have been from wanted
subconscious that this is her
subconscious speaking back to her the
this is the pain that she's been trying
to cover up but it leaks through in
these commercial breaks so
the memory of this of the stark
bombshell that didn't blow up
hydra's brainwashing uh lagos getting
all the people that she accidentally
killed there
uh and then you know the yo magic yogurt
that's that to me is like the hardest
one to interpret but
nexus clearly they're saying like
reality can be whatever you want it uh
because the world doesn't sit around you
or does it yeah and i think
or it does it yeah that tells us that
like this is gonna also be a bit of
house of m
and that by the end of this wanda will
probably set up some kind of multiverse
right
in the mcu um it's just pietro isn't
evidence of the multiverse yeah it's
kind of like we get
we keep getting these fake outs right
mysterio was from the multiverse ah just
kidding
pietro clearly evan peters uh
quicksilver from the fox franchise
no just kidding i think there's going to
be i think the way this hex expands and
then warps
all of the world will be kind of a way
that she shows her
abilities as a nexus being i feel like
every commercial is hitting a lot harder
every time it progressively hits deeper
because when i heard that hydra soaked
one
i was like damn they're just like
punching us in the face with it
and then the yo magic i was like okay
damn we get it she's a survivor like
stop making her relive the hardest parts
and then this one is just like the world
doesn't revolve around yeah
or does it and it's like wow okay so now
you can control anything you want
so i feel like as she progressively gets
more like later into the show we're
gonna get like commercials that are just
rough as hell like the last one's just
gonna be like
you can kill everyone if you want do it
you can leave your friends behind
yeah you can leave your friends behind
murder everybody just to give some
people context in marvel comics about
what next
years are so scarlet witch is one of
them but also
uh jean grey is one of them another
omega level mutant who can kind of
rewrite reality vision
in certain comics kang the conqueror is
a nexus
because what that means is that the
rules of one particular timeline
or reality uh do not confine them
that they can kind of exist outside
separate within the time stream and
we're gonna meet kang the conqueror
in uh ant-man the wasp quantomania and i
think we're gonna get some
uh definitions about what nexus beans
mean to the mcu in loki
because loki has a time variance
authority you could very easily
see owen wilson as mobius and mobius
talking to loki maybe loki could be
defined as a nexus being in the mcu
yeah i mean he's not typically but in
the way that mc is going to do it he
absolutely could be someone who's
detached from timelines now because it's
also
it's like it's someone that's just like
you can be a necromancer
or just like a hexer or just someone
with intense magical ability it's like
any magic
really dark good but just know when you
hear the word nexus that means
multiverse
uh that is a word with x in it that you
can actually look at that letter
x as meaning time to move to another
universe so
it's exciting to hear the word nexus
because i was worried that they weren't
going to explore multiverse
with the way they seem to be uh casting
pietro in this
but we're back in there's so much stuff
that happens in the nexus 2
that they'll probably not get into but
if you read the comics there's just so
much [ __ ] that happens in the nexus that
it's like oh
only the cool of the cool can get into
the next um now by the way if you are
looking for some really really in depth
one division theory discussion in
between these new rockstars video drops
we have an
awesome discord server where pretty much
24 7
clues are being discovered conversations
are happening connections are being made
i call it takes too hot for youtube uh
and you can join the discord community
by becoming
a patron at patreon.comrockstars
exclusive to uh our generous patrons and
it's such a cool place to chat about
this
all right our next one to the jessica
monica
we gotta check out monica she seems to
be powered up now what happened in this
cool moment where she was going through
the barrier
what was that oh my god i loved it i was
so mad a little bit that i was like
oh yeah she it's because in one of the
comics
she gets it by like destroying not a
weapon but just some giant oh my god i
vaguely
like she destroys it it explodes the
combustion with that she gets her powers
so i was like oh it's gonna be the truck
when the truck explodes
it's gonna like cause she made the truck
to her liking
she's gonna it's gonna explode she's to
get powers and then when she
the the truck flew backwards and she ran
through it i was like oh my gosh she
just
she wants to die like she's gonna run
full force through this
and she took off the helmet she took off
her helmet and was like i'm running full
force jimmy was like please don't she
was like
pull my beer watch this ran through and
so
i i was i loved that moment especially
because
her memories were going like timeline
wise they were like
we hear like everything from her audio
from captain marvel we heard the voice
of nick fury in there which is cool
you're going to glow like you're right
yeah and i was like
we're getting it it was so fun to now be
like
to finally see it and be like we're
getting her she's in the mcu now
she has powers you can tell by her eyes
you can't tell but
blue and she was able to see inside west
view
in this weird electromagnetic spectrum
like she could see the radiation for
what it was in that moment which i think
was fascinating
you know so in the post-credits scene
her eyes were glowing purple then
so was she under the spell at that point
do we want to talk about that really
quick
what is that what is is it a spell or is
it like
because i don't think no agatha is
stronger agatha is technically stronger
than
or at least more in control i don't know
if she's stronger but she knows what
she's doing that's true yeah more in
control
um so is she gonna have them do her
bidding or is she just gonna make them
unconscious
um step them out because maybe the next
episode is vision versus agatha
we're gonna see like because they she
just these two are out of the picture
now yeah
for a second i don't know what i think
uh uh
we're gonna see this battle with uh and
i don't know if they're gonna do photon
or spectrum i assume they're gonna call
her photon just because her mom's call
sign was focused yeah because
um but like she's gonna be struggling
against agatha's sorcery
and while she might be able to match
wanda sorcery i don't think she can
overwhelm agatha sorcery yet
and then i think vision's gonna have to
arrive and vision's going to at least
break them free we're gonna see like a
three-on-one battle or something like
that maybe three on two
three on two but uh this is exciting
that like it just seems like
going so now she's been through this
radiation wall what three
times there back in the back end yeah so
that third time was a charm to fully
awaken her uh
so do we think that she had a genetic
predisposition is she gonna be a mutant
or was it just like anyone who goes
through the radiation this much
will have that power i don't think it's
anyone but i think she was special
it sounds so corny but it is also like
and it's a disney movie
so i think she was specific there was
something about her i don't know if it
was some pre
like her dna was already altered but
i don't think someone else could have
like some random sword agent couldn't go
through three times and then turn into
some
sort of superpower being i think it was
specifically monica for
something but i don't know maybe
spending so much time around carol down
it seems like something
yeah we'll talk about that in a second
but real quick yeah let's talk about
this uh
uh wanda the is uh sword's history with
captain marvel it seemed like her friend
uh major goodner was like that's not all
we're loyal to it seems like she was
also
talking about carol danvers but notice
how monica's reaction was kind of like
like mixed there so what do you think
that was what is their history why are
some people like
ashamed to be friends with her whereas
other people are still loyal
i think it's just i think it's just
monica i think everyone else
loves carol danvers because everyone's
like
yeah we know how you feel about our lord
and savior carol danvers and everyone
else is like
uh monica's like no like whatever
i think it's just between monica and her
but i really do want to know what that
beef between her and monica is i keep
saying that it's just that her
mom wasn't there during or she wasn't
there during her mom dying or something
but
there has to be something more she does
not like her yeah there was some
incident
where um you know she's like you're
gonna have to glow like your aunt carol
maybe like uh like young monica
got irradiated at some point but didn't
turn into
a captain marvel or a version of captain
marvel and then that radiation gave her
mom cancer so she kind of blames carol
danvers for that that that's i yeah i
believe that completely and that's why
because that would make sense why she's
so s
like hard for like hating her but yeah
the answer to getting irradiated as a
kid is just
keep irradiating yourself just keep
walking through a wall
and then maybe one day you'll be a
superhero
let alone that's probably a lot of work
and i would not want to do it but like
responsibility it's a great power but
you know great responsibility i want to
lay on my couch
let's talk about major goodner this
whole thing with
one of them was a reveal with monica's
mystery engineer
goodnight doesn't seem like it was
special this wasn't it okay so you think
there's someone else
you built that no there's someone else
it's it's someone else and i can't wait
for blue marble marvel let's get that
guy in a movie i did
well i thought i don't know i might be
thinking
like crazy i put i pitched on twitter i
was like if it's not reed richards why
could it not be blue marvel
and then last night i saw a lot of other
like nerd comedians being like well
can't wait to see blue marvel and i was
like okay now everyone's gonna say oh
here's jessica with her blue marvel
theories
here's jessica with her damn blue marvel
okay all i'm saying is it's black
history month
and not only did they give us monica
becoming her superhero me being like
but if they gave us blue marvel they've
even more it would be eternal
but i don't think this was it i was also
like i was like this isn't it as soon as
she showed up i felt bad for this
person because i was like this isn't
this yeah person oh it's like this is
just the team
delivering it how dare they tv um
uh this whole thing of the there's a
theory that
goodner in that unit could be scrolls
that's what oh i i read something about
that too online and i was like i get
that but also like
how are we supposed to guess that
because jimmy wu wrote scrolls
in episode four and then we're just
supposed to remember that scrolls are
important oh
he took notes from eric voz and wrote
scrolls over and over again
i would be okay with that if they like
at the end all you see is her blink and
it's like a scroll eye
or something i don't know if that's a
thing so i'm going with she's either
this group is either a skrull or it's
just a nothing burger that they weirdly
built up for some reason
i guess it could be scrolls because they
changed their self to look like humans
because jimmy who's with them you can't
trust blue
he does magic don't trust someone who
does magic oh god
the the the takeaway from this entire
show is don't trust magic never
never hire a magician for weddings you
guys so our sixth uh
one of them is this um missing kid on
the milk carton did you catch this
i did and i can't zoom in you always
choose things where i can't zoom in on
it
well you can't really see a name yet
i'll look into this more in the
breakdown but do you think this is
connected with the way wanda brought
kids into west view
oh like the missing that those kids
could be like missing from real life and
then she
sucked them in like a piedmont so dark
she's like i'll give you a home
zoop shoop and brought them in that'd be
pretty dark
that'd be i mean she is slinging a
corpse around so it would not surprise
me that she is
stealing children but then when the hex
is done these children go back to being
like
sad and alone and lost i guess so or
they just go back to their families like
maybe
i mean that would be a weird thing to
show up in west view like
they would already have milk cartons
printed out in the normal world that
this kid's been missing it's only been
like what four or five days
uh-huh it probably is online by now but
i was like i can't zoom in those things
are way too small but you can pause
you can pause and pull the monitor up to
your face that's what i do
oh okay i'm not even wearing my glasses
right now
i'm just like so jessica i don't we have
our what the devil segment here but we
kind of covered that ground
is there any kind of final word you have
on whether this could be mephisto
it was that entire last scene it was all
devil's stuff in there they had the ram
they have a rabbit
if you've seen the [ __ ] so did this
episode i'd
obviously been way too much on this
mephisto train
did this final scene make you more on
the mephisto train or less on the
mephisto train
talking about it out loud with you made
me be like it's definitely if people are
like okay it has to be nightmare memphis
so i'm leaning still
very much mephisto how are you going to
have all this devil stuff in here
but i agnes will be the main villain
and then we'll get like that that like
her partner is mephisto kind of thing
like this
okay this is a person that she's working
with slightly i don't think memphis is
gonna be as big as we wanted him to be
yeah yeah i don't know if i ever wanted
him to be that big of a deal i just
wanted to mention a reference of his
existence that he's somewhere in the
shadows watching all this that's all i
ever really needed well i was on board
with he's like controlling agnes
i was on board especially with that
scene where
uh herb not herb
where herb was like wanda where and we
were trying to figure
out what he was saying if it was like
we're trapped here um
i was like oh what if he's like wanda
agnes has us all here
so i was like well she is it was agatha
all along we just learned that
this is her show and i'm so excited to
see what kathryn hunt does next i can't
well um we're going to wrap it up here
for this youtube
inside marvel after show uh we're going
to be back of course next week
to talk about the biggest wanda the f's
from
episode eight uh and then the breakdown
is coming out tomorrow
those of you listening on stereo we're
coming to you guys now for your
questions
and that uh conversation we're gonna pop
that out and you guys are gonna get some
uh
youtube channel screen time i think on
sunday's video so uh but we're gonna do
that live right now
uh if you missed it uh be sure to
download and follow us on the free
stereo app stereo dot com slash new rock
starts to be part of the fun
we have three new uh live shows uh
monday wednesday friday
jessica thank you so much for joining me
follow jessica at lulu underscore
clemens follow me at ea boss
uh subscribe to new rockstars follow
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast and we're going to close out
with our favorite monday episode
i promise i won't bite i actually did
bite a kid once
[Music]
you